the problem with libraries is that they
can be so large impressive and filled
with knowledge that they unwittingly
embed in us an idea that everything
worth registering everything valuable
and true must lie out there must already
have been classed on a shelf with an
index number to await our discovery the
moment we cease to be so preoccupied
with ourselves
but what this modest respectful and
quietly self-hating conclusion disguises
is that each one of us is an
unparalleled and superlative center of
knowledge in and of ourselves
our minds have more ideas stored in them
than are to be found in the collective
catalogues of the bibliotheca gerald the
universidad their cuimbra the pierpont
morgan library in new york
and the british library in london
we have vaults filled with a greater
number of moving and beautiful scenes
than those of the world's greatest
museums put together
we are just failing to wander the stacks
and galleries as often as we should we
are failing to notice what we have seen
so convinced are we that insights of
worth lie beyond us we have omitted to
consult the treasury of thoughts and
visions generated every hour by our
endlessly brilliant fatefully unexplored
minds
the american essayist ralph waldo
emerson once remarked in the minds of
geniuses we find once more our own
neglected thoughts
in other words geniuses don't have
thoughts that are in the end so very
different from our own they have simply
had the confidence to take them more
seriously
rather than imagining that their minds
are only a pale shadow of the minds of
infinitely greater thinkers who lived
and died elsewhere long ago
they have been respectful enough of
their existence to conceive that one or
two properly valuable ideas might
plausibly choose to alight in the
familiar aviary of their own
intelligences
thinking is
in a way we generally refuse to imagine
a truly democratic activity
we all have very similar and very able
minds where geniuses differ is in their
more confident inclinations to study
them properly
to learn more about the thinkers
featured in our videos check out our
great thinkers book available in print
worldwide and now as an ebook